let's bring our minds back
to actually it might have been
the first or the second lesson within
three dimensional vectors which is kind
of convenient because
we're actually pretty much at the end of
three dimensional vectors you're like
wow did we already get there
yes we did so we were looking at the
three-dimensional coordinate space
right and one of the things we looked at
was like oh how do you represent points
how do you look at them
and then one of the first things that we
then said was actually in three
dimensions
there are some objects which we can
think about as being
very very similar
to objects that we already know this is
the equation the cartesian equation of
the
unit circle right but all you need to do
as we saw many times going from 2d to 3d
all you need to do to turn a circle into
a sphere is
add a z squared right you're like woohoo
i've got a
unit sphere i guess now we left it there
we didn't really touch it at all
actually because then we had to say well
that's kind of nice we get that out of
pythagoras right
because in fact that's a 1 squared if it
were a
sphere of radius 2 it wouldn't be 2 over
there it'd be 2 squared right
but then we kind of left it behind
because we had to get our head back into
just
vector stuff and all the geometric
reasoning we could do with that
but now we're kind of trying to come
full circle
yeah sorry okay it was bad um we're
returning back to this idea because
spheres are really interesting we can do
lots of interesting things with them
this as you recall this is the cartesian
equation
of a sphere but in the last
few lessons we have been exploring the
fact that in three dimensions
it is often very useful to represent
things with a
vector equation now think back with me
right
uh we went from 2d circles to
3d spheres in the cartesian way and it
wasn't too difficult okay
you may need to go back to your previous
notes on this but can anyone remind me
what is the
vector equation of a circle it's a
vector equation
so go ahead value again
r minus
minus whatever vector you have yep so
let's call it c for center right
and then what have i got over here
a radius squared right so um this could
be anything i i've used r over here
which is which is fine
i'm actually just gonna for the sake of
reducing ambiguity right
i'm gonna put radius squared oh yeah no
you're quite right yeah i'm getting i'm
getting cartesian equations
all right now um you may recall from the
complex plane this is exactly what we
saw with saying say
the modulus of z take away whatever
reference point is the circle
uh is the center of your circle yes
we like this because it is even though
the equation the cartesian equation of a
circle isn't too bad this is better do
you agree
now let's think about this what about if
you had a
sphere how would this be
different how would the extension from
two dimensions into three
change this equation
well let's think about it um what is the
definition of
a sphere what is the definition of a
sphere
actually no i should rewind what's the
definition of a circle when dealing with
circles and then using that to extend
the spheres
if someone said to you like rather than
say oh it's a round thing can we
actually we're in extension two now we
can give a proper technical definition
for what a circle is
and you don't want to have a go morgan
so who has a point where you have a
constant radius a circle you start with
a point
right start the point and then you've
got a constant radius that's true
however we're using this
specialized language of circles if
someone didn't know what a circle was
and you said that to them they'd be like
what does that mean okay so we're
talking about distance right there's a
constant distance
from that point to well a whole
bunch of points right we might say back
in complex numbers a
subset of the complex plane because
there's infinitely many of them okay
can you take that very good definition
morgan and extend that
into spheres
yeah this right in the definition you
just gave me you didn't say it but you
actually
implied that we're in two dimensions
right but if we just take that same
definition there's some central point
and then i want that
subset of points that are all the same
distance from that
does that not also equally describe
a sphere so get this right i wonder if
this
rings any bells from when we say did the
3d dot product of um
two vectors right for a sphere
here is the equation in three dimensions
you're like oh if it has the same
geometric
definition it will have the same
equation
um there is one tiny difference though
um what would be the difference to get
us from
2d to 3d it's kind of like tucked in the
way in there kind of hidden
right so again yeah there will be this
extra z just like we had in the
cartesian equation right it's just that
the vector equation part of its point
part of its point is it's succinct all
of that is kind of like hidden inside
r makes sense okay so now we're ready to
have a look at
a question like this if you came a bit
later then maybe jot down a few of these
details
with me we've got two spheres and you
can see the equations of those spheres
have a look with me
you've got r minus and then you've got
this center
point described by that vector there's
the first sphere and it's got a radius
of seven second sphere
different center different radius what
we want to do is show that the spheres
touch each other at a single
point now i want you to ponder this
remember a few of you
arrived early enough that you've been
looking at this question and had it
kicking around in the back your brain
but others this is the first time you've
seen it i'm not worried about the answer
so much
i mean in some ways it's just a proof so
it's like it does
or they do rather we're going to get to
the method in a second but i want you to
think about
how might you geometrically reason this
i'll give you a clue for a start
we've been doing all that thinking about
spheres so far by attaching it to
something that we know pretty well
circles right i'm going to encourage you
to
draw a diagram or a few on your page and
see if you can work out
what might be some calculations that we
can do that can help us
prove that these two spheres do indeed
intersect at just a single
point give you a bit of thinking time
and we'll come back together
and we might just get pens out of hands
for a brief moment i promise you have
enough time to continue thinking about
this because
there won't be that much board work so
it's not like i'm going to rub it off
and you need to like madly catch up so
just pan down and look up
briefly let's think about this question
for a minute because
i feel like you actually learn just as
much from the methods that don't work on
this question
than from the methods that do so think
about what the question is asking and
what might be a normal way to go about
this
you have two things and apparently they
should intersect at exactly
one place now when you are usually
searching for points of intersection
like in the past we've only ever
searched for points of intersection
in a cartesian world so if you get given
two objects right presumably their
equations how would you normally find
the points of intersection between two
things
you would equate them so
simultaneously in some kind of way okay
now just have a look at this
for a moment you immediately run into a
problem whether you go
a vector path or a cartesian path i'll
do it the cartesian way just because i
think it will be more obvious to you
why this is problematic what would be
the cartesian equation
that corresponds to this vector equation
let me give you a clue it's going to
have some of these
and you want to start me off um x minus
five squared
x minus five squared y
y plus six y plus six squared plus
minus three squared okay but before you
go on let's just pause
where did you get all of this this
vector here this is the c vector
it's the center of our sphere right and
we know we can go from
a sphere like this which is a center
aware
on the origin right and all we need to
do is just do a series of translations
in a horizontal vertical
up down no whatever an x and y in a z
direction right
and that will get you to a new center
like the one you want right
and then you would say because we would
get pythagoras out of this we actually
get a pythagorean
quadruple do you remember that what's
going to be on the end here
49 7 squared fantastic okay now when you
come down to this
just for the sake of illustration you
can actually read this off for me can't
you it's going to start with an x and
then
plus 3 y minus 2
z minus 7 and
25 that's the 5 squared okay now just
have a look at this
imagine you're thinking okay i have two
cartesian equations i know how to find
points of intersection
i'm going to solve simultaneously
i don't even want to begin right
because you've got two equations and how
many variables
three no fun don't even start okay
we know enough to know where there's
going to be a dead end in the future
even before beginning
okay not that it would be wrong you will
just not get something useful out of
this and you could do the equivalent
process for vector equations right you
could try and do some
interaction here you will still end up
with an x and y and a z and not enough
information to solve them make sense
so how else can we go about this varene
can you talk us through
even though you didn't originally come
with like a formal way to say this
can you talk us through your way of
doing this and just before you listen to
vran's solution
i'm going to tell you why i went here
first because it is so exceptionally
lazy
that mathematicians would say ah a man
after my own heart okay do you want to
tell us
what you did nice and loud
i found the distance between the two
center points from the spheres
just hold up there hey ain't good make
sure you catch this right
start again veron thank you the distance
between the two center points of this
space okay so i'm going to put a center
here
and a center here for my two spheres and
i've
i've just drawn them as if they're
touching because i've been told so what
was that distance
12. so here is that distance 12.
yes you found that distance by what
method
um no no i just think about it for a
second
i just added i mean i found a b i guess
where the centers
are in b five seven
but you could also say i know the
coordinates of yeah i guess we could
call this a
and call this b right and that gives me
a
i just have to use the distance so i can
just use vector magnitudes right
and you find 12. so then what's your
next step of logic
i added the two radii and if they were
equal to the distance i just found then
it touches at one point
what do you think of that line of
argument it is as i said before
exceptionally lazy in exactly the kind
of way that mathematicians love
i did need these two coordinates right
in order to work out
uh that actual distance a b because
before you know those
you're sort of guessing at this right
except for the question telling you
right
so you go ahead and do that distance it
is 12 5 7
one single point of intersection quite
nice right
so the method that i just demonstrated
works pretty well
and very elegantly for the question as
stated and
to be fair you know the question as that
is very simple just show that the
spheres
touch each other at a single point but
if we want to go further
if the question are something more
sophisticated like say for example
can you find that single point we're
going to need to be a little more
judicious in our use of our vector
geometry and reasoning
and it's not that hard so i want to show
you how we can actually go a little bit
further than what this question
asks to get a little bit more detail
if we just go back to our diagram here
we've got a
circle with center a or rather i should
say sphere with center a and sphere with
center b
set up like so just like you saw on the
board and if i want to find out
what is that point of intersection right
there
i'm going to call it p then i can use
some fairly simp
simple scalar multiples of the vectors
involved here
to find out where p is on the basis of
these two radii here 5
and 7 which are known from me reading
that in the question off of these vector
equations for spheres for example you
can see that i can think of p
as some way along this interval from a
to b which is another way of saying it's
kind of a
scalar multiple of the vector a
b it's just what is the appropriate
multiple so what i want to do first is
work out what this vector a b
is if i write down a b is equal to
and i just need to compare my x and my y
and my z components
to see what kind of change happens in
each of these orthogonal directions
so for instance if i just compare the
x's here's negative 3
and 5 what's the change that gets me
from negative 3
up to 5 it's going to be 8.
what about 2 to negative 6 well
it's also 8 but in the opposite
direction so i'm going to write that as
negative 8 and then my z from 7 down to
3 that's going to be negative 4. so once
i've positioned
a b in this way how far along a b do i
need to go
to get to this point here p and the
answer is if this whole length here is
12
then i need to go 5 12 of the way along
vector av
and that should lay me right at p so how
does the arithmetic
actually play out well you can see here
what i've done is i've set up
let's start from point a right here
negative 3
2 7. there i am and i'm going to go
5 12 of the way along this vector that
i've just written down
8 negative 8 negative 4. so
from here it's really just crunching the
numbers it's just a bit of arithmetic
but there are some things you can do to
make this a bit easier for yourself for
example
in this first line here i should say
second after setting it up
you can see that what i've done is this
first
vector or point a rather the vector to
point a
is unchanged but what i've done on the
right hand side is i've noticed i've got
a common factor of a quarter
and that can cancel with this four that
is a common multiple
or a common factor in through here so
you can see what i've done is that i've
divided everything through here
by four and i've multiplied the
coefficient or the scalar multiple
by four so it's all balanced out once
i've got that
you can see what i've done next is i've
combined these two into one and even
though
all of this is nice and neat and whole
numbers it's going to have to interact
with things in
thirds so i've gotten everything with a
common denominator
thirds thirds thirds off we go and from
there
this is the point that i find now when
you have a look
you do a quick sense check you think
yeah a third that's going to be between
this negative and this positive
it's going to be closer to this negative
one and that makes sense because point p
is five twelfths along the way you can
check all of these
and what's great about this is i sort of
arbitrarily chose
to go from this smaller sphere towards
the largest sphere
there's no reason why i couldn't go in
the opposite direction i can just check
if i get the same thing so for instance
here i've got the circles or the spheres
rather
set up backwards i'm going to start from
the bigger sphere which i had as center
b
and move toward the smaller sphere well
two things are going to change
in this scenario number one instead of
vector a b
i'm going to be dealing with vector b a
so you can see all of my
signs here are backwards to what i had
before negative 8
8 4 as opposed to 8 negative 8
negative 4. so that's backwards and then
the second thing is
in order to get to this point p which
i've not actually labeled on this
particular diagram
instead of going 5 12 of the way from
here
from a i'm going to go 7 12 away from b
so that's why you can see
my start point is different b my
scalar multiple of the vector is
different then i'm going to go from b to
a
and then this is vector b a right here
but as you have a look at the numbers
everything does check out i get the same
coordinates for b
as as you'd really hope just lastly
we looked earlier on right at the start
of this we got these uh cartesian
equations here
for our two spheres we got them but we
determined that
in terms of solving this question they
weren't particularly useful
however now that we've already solved
the question we can actually use the
cartesian equations quite conveniently
to confirm as we've already done a
couple of different ways
that our answer is correct if my answer
is correct
and this point p is the common
intersection point then i should be able
to put this point
into either of these vector equations or
cartesian equations i should say
and they should satisfy right because to
be on the
surface of the sphere the points x y
and z all those coordinates should
satisfy these equations so if you go
ahead and do that
you can see i've highlighted this in
green just so i can make it more obvious
here's me substituting into the first
sphere there's the three x y and z
coordinates
you get a radius of 40. sorry you get a
radius squared
of 49 as you'd expect and then when you
do it in the second sphere same thing
pans out you get a radius of 5 squared
over here as you would expect from the
cartesian
equation so moral of story is
think carefully about how your geometry
fits together and then use your vector
equations in the most simple way you can
like what you've got here the arithmetic
is not complicated it's really the
geometric thinking and the setup
that really is where all your um i would
say your attention and your effort is
going to be focused